จากกล้องโทรทรรศน์ไปจนถึง Large Hadron Collider
เครื่องมือทางวิทยาศาสตร์ใหม่แต่ละชิ้นจะปรับเปลี่ยนคำถาม
ที่เราในฐานะนักวิทยาศาสตร์
และผู้ที่มีความอยากรู้สามารถถามได้อย่างสมเหตุสมผล
การคำนวณสมรรถนะสูงหรือ HPC
เข้าร่วมรายชื่ออันทรงเกียรตินั้นในยุค 60 และวันนี้
quantum computer กำลังเคาะประตูเดียวกัน
ยินดีต้อนรับ ผมชื่อ Conducive to Coffee
และผมเป็น software engineer ที่ IBM Quantum
ในคอร์สนี้เรามุ่งสอนนักศึกษา
และผู้เชี่ยวชาญว่า quantum computing จะ
ทำงานร่วมกับโครงสร้างพื้นฐาน HPC อย่างไร
เพื่อส่งมอบการคำนวณ
คุณจะเรียนรู้ว่า quantum
และคอมพิวเตอร์คลาสสิกสื่อสารและแลกเปลี่ยนข้อมูลกันอย่างไร
วิธีเขียนโปรแกรมที่ใช้ประโยชน์จากฮาร์ดแวร์ทั้งสองประเภท
และการผสานรวมนี้เปิดแอปพลิเคชันที่แก้ได้วันนี้อย่างไร
คุณจะได้รับประสบการณ์จริงกับฮาร์ดแวร์ quantum จริง
และคลัสเตอร์ HPC คลาสสิก
รันงาน quantum ควบคู่กับ workload HPC แบบดั้งเดิม
และเรียนรู้การตีความผลลัพธ์อย่างมั่นใจ
รวมถึงระบุจุดที่ quantum acceleration
จะช่วยการคำนวณได้จริง
และจุดที่ไม่ได้ช่วย เหนือสิ่งอื่นใด คุณจะเข้าใจ
อนาคตของคอมพิวเตอร์กำลังมุ่งไปทางไหน
และแผนที่เก่าที่จะพาเราไปถึงจุดนั้น เราคิดว่า
คอร์สนี้ทั้งสำคัญ
และทันเวลา และเราเชื่อว่า
การรวมเทคโนโลยีเหล่านี้จะเป็นสิ่งจำเป็น
เพื่อบรรลุความได้เปรียบทางการคำนวณ
สิ่งนี้อาจส่งผลกระทบกว้างขวางในหลายอุตสาหกรรม
เช่น เคมี ที่อาจเอื้อให้
การออกแบบยาและวิจัยวัสดุเร็วขึ้น
ในด้านการเงิน
สำหรับโมเดลความเสี่ยงที่ฉลาดขึ้น
และการตรวจจับการฉ้อโกง ในด้าน AI และ machine learning
สำหรับการ optimize โมเดล ในคอร์สนี้
เราจะเจาะลึกทรัพยากรคอมพิวเตอร์
โมเดลการเขียนโปรแกรม และ quantum algorithm
ยินดีต้อนรับและเตรียมตัวให้พร้อม
มีเรื่องต้องพูดคุยเยอะมาก